[Music]
Hollywood is helping to lead the charge
to destroy the National Rifle
Association while giving big-time money
to the broke the pro gun control
campaign but they want to take a stand
against violence they may want to look
at their own material a new study by the
conservative Parents Television Council
finds a dramatic increase in the
portrayals of violence on TV in recent
years according to the study nearly 61
percent of 287 broadcasts primetime
television episodes featured some form
of violence during their November sweeps
period 39% of those 287 shows featured
gun related violence
let's get reaction from actor Antonio
sabato Jr who is also running for for
Congress he joins us now from Calabasas
California we thank you so much for
being here I wanted my friends we're
putting up on this screen you can't see
it but we put it up on the screen this
picture of George Clooney mr. Clooney
has been pretty aggressive about guns
and his belief about gun control right
unique Hollywood's part of the solution
here or is Hollywood part of the problem
now they're part of the problem listen
these are the same people that actually
believed that Hillary Clinton was going
to become the president and was going to
be a good president
she left our people that died in
Benghazi let's not forget that these are
the same people that went to the Academy
Awards the other day protected by LAPD
bodyguards wearing pieces you know guns
all over the place at the Academy Awards
and then they're making movies on a
weekly basis with guns that they want to
banned you know the NRA is done more to
protect the American people then
Hollywood could ever do so let's talk
the truth here and make sure the
American people know what's going on
here and I think they know that because
we elected Donald Trump he's doing an
amazing job and and that's why I'm
running for office and November I'm
gonna win because we got to bring common
sense back into government and and to
our common our daily lives I mean we
can't live with these lies every single
day the media is spilling lies 24 hours
a day against our president against the
Republican Party that's all they do and
this time they're not gonna win because
the American people have woken up we
want our America back and we got to
protect our American our Constitution so
what do you think is Hollywood's
responsibilities should they I mean
they're entrepreneurs and they just
often I mean the reason they make movies
with guns and it's because Americans go
to them and they pay money to go see
them so is it their responsibility or
should we just call out their hypocrisy
what's the right answer for if they want
to talk about gun-free zones and always
blame it on the NRA then hip then they
are the hypocrites but listen right now
why don't they make more movies about
positive stuff what about Family Values
what about God wants in a while what
about you know the Ten Commandments what
about good stuff positive stuff loving
caring stuff and I'm not talking about
the Disney movies I'm talking about
general what do we do that TV shows that
involves God and then family and sitting
down at the table and things like that
you know I urge him to do that you know
we got to come together and talk about
the real stuff here the problems are not
the guns the problems are the people who
are pulling the trigger
like what we've seen in Florida and and
and then we keep voting these people who
are our sheriff's are people in
government who cannot protect the
American people and this happened in
Florida so right now we have to educate
people and tell them the truth do you
think they you know the breakdown of the
family is it seems to be a common
denominator with a lot of these kids
they can't distinguish right from wrong
there may be some mental incompetency
may have a breakdown in the family this
Hollywood believe in any of that
I don't know listen we have so many
issues right now the opioid epidemic
people are addicted kids are addicted to
Medicare you know a medicated stuff and
and and that's really bad I mean people
are not sitting around with their kids
anymore and talking about what's going
on in your life can I get to know you do
you want to get to know me
it's always about computers and phones
and this and that and all these
distractions we had guns in this country
for 200 years and all of a sudden we're
having these these problems happening
every single week and I always want to
blame it on guns let's blame it on
people let's blame it on society and
let's bring love and happiness and
family values back into our daily lives
well listen I think you I think there
are a lot of kids out there they can't
distinguish right from wrong it's like a
it's like a puddle of gasoline and then
they said 15 hours and watch a video
game or go watch a violent movie and
it's like throwing a match on that
gasoline and and kaboom and I left
I mean these kids are left alone there's
no more communication between the
teachers and the parents anymore parents
cannot walk into a school and and and
you know and talk about their issues and
with the school itself all these
regulations and this and that so we're
not really free anymore they want to
hold us hostage and you know we don't
have Bibles in schools anymore they
wanted to take our American anthem away
we don't respect the flag
y'all I'm fighting for what is right and
we gotta you know we gotta fight for the
flag and we gotta fight for this country
we have 26 beautiful amendments we got
to keep them there one of them as a
Second Amendment and Antonio sabato jr.
from California we thank you for joining
us